back to the special edition of the five
president trump calling out the media
during a testy thanksgiving news
conference
watch this don't talk to me that way
you're just a you're just a lightweight
don't talk to me that way don't talk to
i'm the president of the united states
don't ever talk to the president
that way all right i'm going to go with
another question go ahead
and the cnn reporter being criticized
after boasting on twitter congratulating
herself
and her colleagues on president trump
answering questions for the first time
in three weeks
um you know tom i'm gonna go with you
first on this i saw that picture on
twitter and the first thing that caught
me is just a little off was
you had nine people congregating in this
one picture kind of reminiscent of those
hollywood award shows i mean instead of
talking about the soldiers who are away
from their families or the 250 000
americans who have recently died in the
pandemic
i mean what is your take on the
self-congratulatory tone of these
journalists
at a time when we're supposed to be
reflecting on being grateful
oh it's been happening since election
day we had the times reporter the other
day celebrating
saying that the cabinet picks uh joe
biden's cabinet picks
look like marvel superheroes uh
you know the uh they'll never stop
patting themselves on the back
they were part of the resistance they
were proud of that i love that donald
trump
was getting snippy with these reporters
because everyone was talking about
dignity the dignity of the office but
these reporters have never had any
dignity
nancy pelosi did i want to ask did
president trump ever do anything
as undignified as ripping up that state
of the union speech
find something that he did in the office
that was that undignified
and for these hypocrites to talk about
dignity nancy pelosi who closes salons
and then gets her hair done and then
blames it on them
i mean how undignified is nancy pelosi
and all the democrats including chuck
schumer and everybody else who complains
about
dignity the dignity of the oval office
the president was right and you know
what he was protecting joe biden because
he said don't ever
talk to the president that way so he's
protecting all future presidents from
this predatory press
well tom you know uh pelosi and gavin
newsom they're just following the
science right
yes jessica so i go to you you know the
president
is criticized often for his own
self-congratulatory tone
um but my question to you is do you
actually think that the media portrays
him fairly do they
portray his successes to discuss his
successes like operation warp speed
or do they really only focus on his
blunders
i think there are certainly more
blunders than successes so
that should be proportionate but we know
that he has an incredibly antagonistic
relationship with the press
and that he gets a tremendous amount of
negative coverage for it
if you're calling people fake news to
their face they're going to get upset
about it
and i think the reporting is going to
reflect that now we've covered
what it's not their job to do that their
personal opinions
shouldn't be no but you are you just
to be fair you're saying that because
the president
was mean and said some nasty thing to
the press that the press shouldn't cover
the stories accurately
and that's just simply not true just
because they i there's a lot of policies
actually i hate them all i hate policies
but it's our job to give our viewers
the information that that matters to
them
and that's not what they're doing when
they're in those press rooms and you
know that because the
this was the first opportunity you saw
that they were complaining that they
hadn't gotten a press conference
meanwhile joe biden got to sit in his
basement for the majority of the
campaign
and the first time they had the
opportunity to ask him questions they
give him all these layups
it just shows you the difference and i'm
not saying you can't like the president
like
don't like him go home and rant about it
to your wife or a husband but at the
same time your job is not to put your
personal shield on
is to give the audience the information
that they deserve i was just trying to
add some color to how the relationship
got to this point and i'm not saying
that it's appropriate but there are some
phenomenally good reporters like jeff
mason for instance who the president
goes after relentlessly
even mocking him for wearing a mask even
though it's cdc guidelines and he says
that he's showing off right he wants to
be all pc
and i think that that is a problem and
that the relationship with the press is
fractured i want joe biden's feet to be
held to the fire as well i think it's
important do you think he will
do you think it will i well i i think
that it will to some degree i don't
think it'll look like what goes on with
president trump but
joe biden's going to run a transparent
administration where he's not going to
be breaking norms like this on a daily
basis
his feet are held to the fire he's
curled up right now in front of a fire
as we speak
well and you know emily governor cuomo
just this weekend in radio interviews
said he's actually never seen disrespect
towards a president the way that he's
seeing against president trump right now
do you think that this is going to
change if biden becomes president when
biden is called in the office in january
well i certainly think the contempt will
stop the visible contempt will stop
i'm not sure however if 180 degree
pendulum shift
is any more healthy meaning i think the
softball questions and i think we all
agree to this
uh do no one any favors right that if
there's sort of this
simpering warship or just again that
what socks is he wearing
without really digging in without really
uncovering policy you know
he's he said that he can have a green
new deal-ish
environmental friendly policy for the
entire nation that would keep union
members employed
let's get the details on that that's
just one example of a million
but i have to say i don't know in terms
of trump i don't know if that bell can
be unrun
unrung meaning it's almost like watching
you know a couple friend of yours
that they're married but they hate each
other and you're just watching these two
have contempt
for each other and you're like i don't
think that they can ever go back so i
think for this particular relationship
with this particular president
i don't think there's i don't think
there's any healing there
we're not inviting you over anymore
emily
that's not me
all right well we have to leave it there
and